مرحبًا بكم في مكتبة
الكونغرس ، مكتبة الكونغرس هي أكبر
مكتبة في العالم تقع في
واشنطن العاصمة ، هذه المجموعة التي تضم أكثر من
160 مليون عنصر هي أرشيف
ضخم لتاريخ الولايات المتحدة ،
وهناك أكثر من 70 مجموعة خاصة
تتضمن مخطوطات نادرة  الموسيقى ورقة الخرائط
وأكثر من ذلك بكثير ، مرحبًا أنا
مدير قنب الحبر في هيلينا للمجموعات
وأيضًا رئيس المطبوعات والصور
يقسم هذه المجموعة من الصور التي
يزيد عددها عن 15 مليونًا من بين
أندر الصور في مجموعتنا ،
لدينا الأم المهاجرة المرأة الأيقونية التي
تمثل  خلال فترة الكساد الكبير بأكملها
، تجمع الصور بين الأشخاص الذين
يدعونك إليها للنظر حولك واستكشاف
عوالم قد لا تتمكن أبدًا من
رؤيتها شخصيًا ،
مرحبًا ، أنا بوليت هزيل ، أنا
رئيس قسم الجغرافيا والخرائط
لدينا خمسة ملايين وخمسة ملايين  خرائط
ألف أطلس وخمسمائة كرة أرضية
لدينا خرائط لويس وكلارك
خرائط جورج واشنطن
لدينا أول  الخريطة التي تُظهر
اسم أمريكا عليها ، نحن جزء من
عالم أوسع وأوسع ، وبينما ننظر إلى
بعض هذه الأدلة الخرائطية
للتغيرات بمرور الوقت ،
فإننا ندرك أننا كأمة قد تغيرنا بمرور
الوقت ، مرحبًا أنا أقاضي فيتا  رئيس
قسم الموسيقى ، هناك حوالي 24
مليون عنصر في المجموعة الموسيقية ،
لدينا آلات ستراديفاري ، ولدينا موسيقى
الرابسودي الأصلية باللون الأزرق ، تخبرنا النسخة الأصلية
من موسيقى الراية ذات النجوم المتلألئة
بالمزيد
عن هويتنا وتخبرنا عن موقعنا  الماضي في مستقبلنا
[موسيقى]
مرحباً اسمي مايكل نورث وأنا رئيس
خدمات المراجع والقراء في قسم
الكتب النادرة والمجموعات الخاصة
في مكتبة الكونغرس ، تحتوي هذه
المجموعة على أكثر من مائة ألف
عنصر لدينا كل شيء من مخطوطات العصور الوسطى
الكتب المبكرة المطبوعة ، Bly
breeze of Thomas Jefferson ، أحد
أشهر كتبنا هو كتاب Gutenberg Bible ،
ومن المهم أن يكون لديك سجل
للماضي حتى نعرف كيف وصلنا إلى
ما وصلنا إليه  اليوم على حد سواء من حيث
الأفكار ومن حيث التاريخ والسياسة ،
فن كل شيء مرحبًا
أنا Malia Walker أنا
أمين مكتبة مرجعي في المسلسل الخاص
بقسم المنشورات الحكومية ، هذه المجموعة
ضخمة لدينا ثمانمائة ألف
بكرة من الميكروفيلم
لدينا حوالي 7.2 مليون  أعداد فضفاضة
من الصحف وما يقرب من 42000
مجلد من صفحات الجرائد المجمدة لدينا أيضًا
حوالي مائة وأربعين
ألف عدد من الكتب المصورة ، أحد
الأشياء العظيمة في قراءة
الصحف هو أنك تحصل على فكرة
عما يشبه أن تكون في أمريكا التي
تقرأها  كيف عاش الناس
مجموعات التاريخ نفسه هي طريقتنا لإضافة
الذاكرة والتذكر ، كل
المجموعات تعطي معنى وسياقًا
للتجربة الإنسانية وتاريخ
الثقافة
[موسيقى]